[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم فدى باسيله
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى نبدا من هذه الصور التي
تاتينا مباشره من الخرطوم في السودان
والتي شهدت اليوم تصاعدا كبيرا في
الاشتباكات والمواجهات
نتابع هذه الصور وهي تتاهب جويا مع مدن
اوكرانيه اخرى لمزيد من الضربات الروسيه
بحسب اعلان وزاره الدفاع
اما هذه الصور فهي من اواشنطن حيث يستمر
ايجاز البيت الابيض في تصدير المواقف بشان
العديد من القضايا والملفات
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
تصاعد حدث المعارك والاشتباكات في الخرطوم
قوات الدعم السريع تقول انها تحاصر مقر
القياده العامه والجيش المغارات على مواقع
لها ومع استمرار المحادثات في جده طرف
صراع يؤكدان اقتصارها على وقف اطلاق النار
وتامين الممرات الانسانيه وكانت الصحافه
الفرنسيه تنقل عن دبلوماسي سعودي عدم
احراز المباحثات تقدما كبيرا
وسط ترقب لهجوم اوكراني مضاد قائد فاغنري
يؤكد تلقيه امدادات عسكريه وبدا هجوم مكثف
في باخموت والقوات الروسيه توسع موجه
ضرباتها على كييف ومدن اخرى وعشيه
احتفالات روسيا بذكرى النصر على النازيه
تخوف اوكراني من هجوم واسع النطاق غدا
وبعد خمس سنوات على انسحاب الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب من الاتفاق
النووي جمود مستمر في مسارفينا التفاوضي
ايران تقول ان احياء الاتفاق امر ممكن
وتحذر من اي استهداف لمصالحها القوميه
ومتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه يقول
للجزيره ان واشنطن تتمسك بنهج الدبلوماسيه
وانها ستمنع ايران من امتلاك سلاح النووي
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاه على منصاتنا
الرقميه تحدثنا عن الخلاف الذي يشوب
العلاقات الاوروبيه الاسرائيليه بعد قرار
بعثه الاوروبيه الغاء حفل الاستقبال
السنوي الذي يقام في تل ابيب في كل عام
بمناسبه يوم اوروبا وذلك بعد قرار حكومه
نتنياهو اختيارا الوزير اليمني المتطرف
للمشاركه فيه والقاء كلمه وهو ما كان
مرفوضا مسبقا من قبل الاوروبيين
والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي هل سيؤثر
الخلاف الاوروبي الاسرائيليه على حضور بنت
فير دوليا جاءت الاجابات على هذا النحو 60
في المئه قالوا انه سيحد من حضوره اما 40%
فارقوا انه لا يؤثر على حضوره دوليا
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
رويترز تتحدث عن ضربات اردنيه على جنوب
سوريا استهدفت مصنع مخدرات مرتبطا بايران
ووزير الخارجيه يقول ان بلاده ستعلن عن اي
تحرك لحمايه امنها القومي في الوقت
المناسب
[موسيقى]
البدايه من المشهد السوداني الذي بدا
محتدما اليوم مع تصاعد المعارك في الخرطوم
حيث سمعت الانفجارات مع تصاعدي اعمده
الدخان في محيط القصر الجمهوري وبحسب
مراسلنا فان المضادات الارضيه التابعه
للدعم السريع ردت على طلعات جديده للجيش
في الخرطوم بحري ياتي ذلك مع استمرار
محادثات ممثلين عن الطرفين في مدينه جده
السعوديه وهي مباحثات اكدت قوات الدعم
السريع اختصارها على الهدنه والجوانب
الانسانيه بينما نقلت وكاله الصحافه
الفرنسيه عن دبلوماسيه سعوديا قوله انها
لم تحرز تقدما كبيرا حتى الان مؤكدا ان
الوقف الدائم لاطلاق النار ليس مطروحا وان
كل جانب يعتقد انه قادر على حسم المعركه
ينضم الينا من ام درمان مراسل جزيره هيثم
اويت ومن جده مراسل جزيره بدر البعان هيثم
ابدا معك مع اخر التطورات الميدانيه
واصداء ما يجري في جده من مباحثات
الميدانيه هدوء
الان مدن الخرطوم الثلاث بعد ان كانت هناك
معارك ضاريه في هذا اليوم كانت المواجهات
حاضره في كل من الخرطوم والخرطوم البحري
وكانت اشرسها في منطقه الخرطوم وسط
الخرطوم تحديدا حيث كانت هناك العديد من
الطلبات الجويه التي نفذها سلاح الجو
التابع للجيش السوداني على مواقع
لقوات الدعم السريع والتي هي ردت بدورها
بالمضادات الارضيه التي انطلقت من انحاء
عديده تجاه الطائرات التي يبدو انها قصفت
العديد من المواقع وكانت اعمده الدخان قد
تصعدت في العديد من المواقع في وسط
الخرطوم محيط القصر الرئاسي وكذلك في
منطقه بحري بالخرطوم هذه المواجهات تاتي
في وقت ما تزال فيه الانظار متجهه الى جده
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه في انتظار ما
تتبخر عنه هذه المحادثات بجاني الهدن او
الهدن التي يتوقع في حال توصلت الاطراف
الى صيقه اتفاق خاصه ان الدخل السليمان
هنا يعول على هذه الخطوه كثيرا باعتبارها
المخرج الاساسي من المواجهات المستمره
وانها تتيح الفرصه لفتح الممرات الانسانيه
الامنه وتسهيل حركه المواطنين والقضاء
حاجياتهم وكذلك فتح الطرق الامنه لمن
يريدون الخروج من داخل الاحزاب السياسيه
والبيانات كلها ترحب بي المفاوضات الجاريه
رغم الانباء التي تقول بان هناك بعض
التعثر في مساله الوصول الى اتفاق مبدئي
في وقف اطلاق النار ولكن ما زالت الامل
معلقه على هذه المفاوضات حتى الان بدل
انتقل عناوين هذه المحادثات باتت واضحه
ولكن ماذا في التفاصيل
نعم فداء اليوم نحن في نهايه اليوم الثالث
من هذه المفاوضات المحاطه بحقيقه بالسياد
من السريه والتي تجري بين طرفي النزاع
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع بحسب
مصادر المطلعه فان عمليه التفاوض الغير
مباشره ما تزال محصوره في التوصل الى هدنه
انسانيه قصيره لفتح ممرات امنه للمساعدات
الانسانيه ايضا ذات المصادر اكدت انها لم
تتطرق الى وقف اطلاق نار دائم او اي جنده
سياسيه اخرى بيان وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
جاء ليؤكد ان هذه المحادثه المباحثات
الاوليه وتهدف الى التركيز على التخفيف
اثار الصراع المدنيين وهذا ما تجلس من اجل
الوفود المفاوضه في في جده في اضافه الى
تحقيق وقف فعال قصير المدى لاطلاق النار
وايضا فتح الممرات الانسانيه الامنه لعبور
والمساعدات وكذلك وضع جدول زمني لمفاوضات
موسعه للوصول لوقت دائم للاعمال العسكريه
يبدو انه لا مؤشرات على وقف الصراع
العسكري الدائره الحاليه في السودان ايضا
من الواضح انه لا يوجد سقف زمني لهذه
المباحثات الاوليه تجري بشكل غير مباشر
هنا في جده نتحدث عن البيان يتناول تفاصيل
هذه المحادثات ويصدر من الجانب السعوديه
المستضيف لها والتي يسعى رعاتها السعوديون
الامريكيون من اجل رفعها الى مستوى
ومفاوضات جاده حقيقه السعوديه معنيه بشكل
مباشر باداره هذه الازمه ووضعها في سياق
خارطه طريق واضحه للوصول الى حلول على
الصعيد السياسي والانساني والعسكري ايضا
وبحثات تجري حاليا بواساطه سعوديه امريكيه
بحضور ممثلي للرباعيه الدوليه اضافه الى
مبعوث الامم للسودان رئيس الوفد السوداني
كان قد اكد ان ما يتم البحث عن حاليا هو
هدنه انسانيه قصيره لفتح ومرات امنه
للمساعدات الانسانيه وايضا ممرات لتامين
العمليات الاجلاء قال ايضا المفاوضات ما
زالت مستمره الجيش السوداني ياتي الى
طاوله المباحثات في جده بالمواقف معلنه
وثابته هي تثبيت الهدن والالتزام بها ايضا
ومدى جديه الطرف الاخر قوات الدعم السريع
في وقف اطلاق النار وفتح الممرات وتامين
عمليات الاجلاء الرياض واشنطن كانت حتى
اطرافه النزاع هنا في جده على الانخراط
بجديه في هذه المحادثات وايضا وضع مناخ
ايجابي لها بعيدا عن اي توترات تجري على
الارض هناك بخصوص العمليات العسكريه
الجاريه في السودان شكرا لك كنت معنا بدر
ربيعان من جده وشكر موصول ايضا لهيثم اويد
مراسل جزيره من ام درمان
ينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو على
البروفيسور محمد الحسن لباد مدير ديوان
رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي اهلا بك
اسمع منك بدايه تعليق على ما يجري في جده
من محادثات والعناوين المطروحه في هذه
المحادثات الحقيقه المعلومات الوارده من
جده ما تزال شحيحه الى حد كبير
ولا يمكننا في هذه اللحظه ان نحكم على مدى
نجاحها او لا قدر الله اخفاقها ولكن
الامان المعقوده عليها ان تتوصل على الاقل
الى وقف اطلاق النار بصوره جديه وملزمه
للطرفين وفتح بسرعه
ممرات
لاغاثه الانسانيه من دواء وغذاء
ومساعدات
للموازين وكذلك ايضا لنجده
الالاف بل تكون الملايين من الناس الذين
نجحوا من المدن التي شهد
هذا يقودنا للسؤال عن الى اين وصلت جهود
الاتحاد الافريقي في هذا الاطار الاتحاد
الافريقي بادر منذ اللحظات وانتم تعرفون
الدوله الذي لعبه الاتحاد الافريقي منذ
سنه 2019 والاتفاق الذي توصل اليه الذاكره
من اجل الترتيبات لمرحله انتقاليه يتولى
تم تنظيم
انتقاليه يتبوا فيها الرياده بطبيعه الحال
واطيح بها سنه 2001 للانقلاب 25 اكتوبر
وبدات مفاوضات من جديد
وكان قد اقترب الناس من العسكريون
والمدنيون من اتفاق كان له عوره بودع في
تصحيح ذلك العور وحدث ما حدث من كارثه او
طعمه سميته طامه كبرى في السودان
الامر المستعجل هو ان يوقف الاقتتال لانه
تدمير البنى التحتيه الانسانيه
والاقتصاديه والجامعيه والصحيه وتدمير
سمعه السودان ومكانه ووجه السودان الجميل
والشعب العظيم هذه لا يمكن ان تستمر باي
حال من الاحوال طيب كيف يمكن تحقيق ذلك ما
الادوات التي يمتلكها الاتحاد الافريقي من
اجل تحقيق ذلك سيده الفاضله اداتان
اساسيتين الاولى هي ان يقوم الشعب
السوداني بقواه المدنيه والاجتماعيه
والدينيه وغير ذلك برفع صوتهم القوي بصوره
مدويه لايقاف الاقتتال هذا ضروري وهذا شرط
اول وفي مقدور الشعب السوداني ان يقوم به
وعليه ان يقوم به وبدون قيامه به لا يمكن
ان نامل بحلها
الميكانيزم الثاني هو المنظومه الدوليه
وهنا الاتحاد الافريقي اتخذها مبادره
اتخذها رئيسه الاتحاد الافريقي السيد
مصطفى محمد السريعه جدا فجمع كوكبه من كل
اجسام المنظومه الدوليه في اجتماع رفيع
المستوى جدا يوم 20 ابريل الماضي ثم
ادى ذلك الى تشكيل اليه جامعه لاننا لا
نؤمن بالتدخلات اجنبيه متشعبه ومتفرقه
فالمنظومه الدوليه من اجل ان تكون فعاله
وان يكون عملها ذا مردوديه يجب ان تعمل
الاتحاد وهذا ما يسعى اليه الاتحاد
الافريقي هل ترى ان المبادرات اليوم تمشي
بتناسق مع بعضها البعض هنالك مبادرات
مختلفه ام تتعارض في بعض الاحيان مع بعضها
البعض كل الذين يحاولون ان يلعبوا دورنا
الان يركزون على نقاط ثلاثه عليها اتفاق
عليها عامه وهي ايقاف الحرب فتح فتح
الممرات الانسانيه
واعاده المسار السياسي هذه الثلاثيه
ولكن لن في اتفاقهم هذا جدوى فعلي اذا لم
يعملوا سويا في بوتقه واحده وهذا ما نسى
اليه نحو الامم المتحده ان يتم في اسرع
الاوقات واماني كبير بان الايام القادمه
سنتوصل الى صيغه الجامعه لكل مكونات
المنظومه الدوليه بهذا الصدد طيب ذكرت
الامم المتحده الامين العام للامم المتحده
قام بجوله زارع اثيوبيا تحدث فيها عن
مخاطر ان يؤدي هذا الخلاف داخل السودان او
المواجهات ان ينتقل الى دول الجوار ما
جديه هذه المخاوف
حقيقيه ونحن نحاول اعيد كلمه نحن نحاول ان
نجمع الجامعه العربيه الاتحاد الافريقي
الامم المتحده الاتحاد الاوروبي المنظمه
الجهويه للايجاد وبعض الدول ايضا الفاعله
مثل الرباعيه الى اخره في منطقه واحده
عندما تقولون كلمه تحاولون هل نجحتم لا
الاجتماعات حصلت والاتفاق على هذا حصل
ولكن
يعني لاعمال هو قيد هو قيد
طبيعي انه اذا لم نتوفر نوفق في ان نوقف
هذا الاقتتال ونعود الى حل سلمي لاننا لا
نؤمن لا انا لا اعتقد ابدا واكررت هذا
مرارا لا نؤمن باي حال من الاحوال ان لهذا
الصراع حل عسكري لن يكون هنالك منتصر
نهائي عسكريا وهذه مساله وهميه والذين
يحاولون ان يتاجروا بها مهما كانت الطرف
الذي ينتمون اليه انما يتاجرون باوهام لا
اساس لها لانه لابد ان يكون الحل سياسي
فاذا لم يتم بطبيعه الحال
الازمه
قد يكون سيلها القاتل والخانق مدمر
بالنسبه للمنطقه كلها لا اريد ان اسميها
بعض الدول ولكن قله من الدول يمكن ان
تقاوم الفوضى اذا عمت في هذه المنطقه فسال
محمد يعني سؤال اخير كان لديك كتاب عنوان
السودان على طريقه المصالحه نبات فيه
بامكانيه ان تحصل مواجهات على ماذا اعتمد
في ذلك لا اريد ان ارجع الى عمل شخصي قمت
به شخصيا منذ ثلاث سنوات ولكن
تبين لي لما وقعنا الاتفاق سنه 2019 وهذا
ما كتبته ان هنالك
ثغرات كثيره جدا منها تشعب القوه العسكريه
التي تحمل السلاح في معظم المدن وهذا مثلا
منها ضعف ثقافه الحكم لدى كثير من القوى
المدنيه التي التجربه ومنها ايضا هو فقدان
القدره النفسيه والسياسيه على التسامي على
ضعف الانسان من انانيات وحب السلطه الى
غيره كل هذه الامور اثرتها ومع الاسف وهذا
الم الشديد هو ان تلك الاشياء التي ذكرتها
سنه 2019 في ذلك الكتاب الذي اشرت اليه مع
الاسم الشديد ادت بناء الى ما نحن فيه طيب
اشرت الى نقطه وتحدثت عنها هي تشعب القوى
التي تحمل السلاح الى حد الان هذه القوه
لم تتدخل
بتقديرك كيف يمكن قراءه ذلك متى متى ستبقى
بدون تدخل انا اخاف ان بعض القوه لم تدخل
المعركه الان قد تدخلها الى هذه الطرف او
ذلك هل هذا محتمل على الرغم من
ما لم يحصل حل سياسي سريع ونهضه قوميه في
السودان والشعب السودان ونخب السودان
المدنيه والعسكريه كل الاحتمالات
مفتوحاتهم مع الاسف اني انا سالت ان كان
ذلك محتملا بالنظر الى التوازنات القبليه
للجانبين ممكن ممكن مع الاسف ولذلك يجب ان
نسارع في الجهود التي الداعيه الى وقفي
الاقتتال شكرا لك البروفيسور محمد الحسن
العباد مدير ديوان رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي كنت معنا هنا في الاستوديو شكرا
الى اوكرانيا حيث تواعد او تعود العاصمه
كييف الى واجهه الاحداث كهدف ابرز للقصف
الروسي المتواصل منذ ايام على العاصمه
ومدن اخرى في البلاد هذا وتتخوف الاداره
الاوكرانيه من طلاق هجوم كبير غدا تزامنا
مع احتفالات موسكو بيوم النصر على النازيه
ياتي ذلك في وقت يتزايد فيها الحديث عن
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد خلال هذا الشهر
لوهله اعتقد سكان العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف
ان الحرب ابتعدت عنهم لاشهر كانت سماء
العاصمه هادئه لا يعكر صفوها ضجيج الحرب
المستعره في الجنوب والشرق لكن اسراب
الطائرات المسيره غيرت هذا الواقع في وقت
وجيز 60 طائره مسيره هجمت العاصمه خلال
يوم واحد في هجوم هو الاكبر من نوعه بحسب
عمده المدينه كما اعلن الجيش الاوكراني ان
روسيا هاجمت المقاطعات الجنوبيه من
زبروجيا ودينيبرو شرقا الى اوديسا غربا
مرورا بميكولايف وخلص وسط البلاد بمختلف
انواع الاسلحه من غارات جويه وقذائف
صاروخيه اما على جبهه بخموت فتتحدث هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه عن صد 50 هجوما
صاروخيا واتهمت موسكو باستعمال القذائف
الحارقه وماده الفوسفور الابيض المحرم
استعمالها دوليا ضد المدنيين
التي تستمر المحاولات الروسيه للسيطره
عليها رغم ما يبدو من خلافات وانتقادات
للجيش الروسي من قوه فاجنر اما فخار كيف
فعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه استعمالها
قاذفات استراتيجيه لقصف من قالت انهم
مرتزقه اجانب كما قالت انها دمرت مجموعتين
اوكرانيتين في مقاطعه كوبيانسك
واستهداف كبرى المدن الاوكرانيه يخشى
المسؤولون في كيف ان الاسوا لم يحدث بعد
حيث تتداول على اعلى المستويات في كييف
انباء عن هجمات اشد ستستهدف اوكرانيا
بالتزامن مع ذكرى النصر على النازيه التي
تحتفل بها روسيا في التاسع من مايو ايار
لا نعرف لماذا تشن كل هذه الهجمات الضخمه
في شهر مايو ومن الصعب للغايه تحليل سلوك
العدو وان كان لا يمكننا التاكد من الهدف
الذي وجهت اليه الطائرات بدون طيار الا
اننا نفترض انه من الممكن ان تكون مراكز
صنع القرار من بين تلك الاهداف حيث انهم
صرحوا مرارا وتكرارا انه بعد الضربات على
البنيه التحتيه ستكون مراكز صنع القرار هي
الهدف وفي بيان اللافت تحدث الجيش
الاوكراني عن انسحاب قيادات روسيه من مقر
وادارات يسيطرون عليها في خرسون باتجاه
شبه جزيره القرم واضاف البيان ان القوات
الاوكرانيه رصدت انسحابا مماثل في مدن
ومناطق خاضعه للسيطره الروسيه في المقاطعه
الجنوبيه
قال مؤسس شركه فاغنر ان مجموعته بدات
بتلقي الامدادات العسكريه بعد انقطاع
وانها كثفت هجماتها لفرض السيطره على
المدينه ياتي ذلك بوقت قال فيه متحدث باسم
القياده الشرقيه الاوكرانيه ان الروسي
يواصلون محاولاتهم للسيطره على مدينه
شرقي البلاد وان قوات فاجنر تعاني من
خسائر بشريه كبيره
فالجيش الروسي هناك يطلق يوميا حوالي 25
الف قذيفه تصريحات قائد فاجنر الاخيره
سببها الصراع الداخلي بينه وبين القياده
العسكريه الروسيه السبب الرئيسي لتصريحات
مالك هو انه تعهد بالتزامات عسكريه لكنه
غير قادر على الوفاء بها بما في ذلك
السيطره على ضخمه
ينضم الينا من بيروت العميد الياس حنان
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه عميد الياس
هجوم وصف بانه الاكبر على العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كييف وكذلك هنالك هجمات ايضا
متصاعده على عدد من المدن في اوكرانيا ما
هي ابرز الملاحظات التي يمكن تسجيلها من
الناحيه العسكريه بدايه بهجوم كياف
هذه هذا نمط روسي تجاه القصف بدا منذ
اسقاط او اغراق البارجه موسكو تدمير او
ضرب او تفجير جسر قرش وبالتالي منذ مجيء
الجنرال الى القياده في خرسون بدات هذه
العمليات يعني اليوم نحن في عمليه متكرره
هذا نمط اساسي اليوم يختلف الوضع
التحضير الاوكراني للهجوم اول نقطه ثاني
نقطه الهجوم بالمسيرات على الكرملين
وبالتالي قد يكون هناك اعاده تكوين
المخزون الروسي ان كان من المسيرات او حتى
من الصواريخ 60 مسيره على كييف ما الرساله
التي تحاول روسيا ايصالها الى الجانب
الاوكراني وهل هي تتعلق او ترتبط بالهجوم
المضاد التي تبشر به اوكرانيا ام بما جرى
على الكرملين
ثلاث نقاط النقطه الاولى الرد على
المسيرات فوق هذا اثنين يوم النصر ضد
النازيه ثلاثه هي محاوله استنزاف كل
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه الى المدى
الاقصى خاصه اذا تذكرنا ان التسريبات
الامريكيه حول الاستعلام تقول انه خلال
هذا الشهر او الشهر القادم
ستستنفذ اوكرانيا كل الدفاعات الجويه
بانتظار ان ياتي اسلحه او صواريخ مضاده
ارض جو فازا كل هذه العوامل مع بعضها
البعض ولكن بالتاكيد اليوم ذكرى يوم النصر
وحتى التحضير ومحاوله استنزاف كل الصواريخ
او الترسانه الدفاعيه لاوكرانيا
داخل اوكرانيا هنالك من يتوقع هجوم اكبر
في ذكرى التاسع من مايو وهي ذكرى النصر في
روسيا هل تشاركون هذا التوقع مع هؤلاء
بالطبع يعني يريد الرئيس بوتين اليوم قد
يكون هذا احدى التحليلات ولكن يستلزم
استعلام تكتي واستعلام استخبارات لمعرفه
النوايا ولكن دون شك حتى الان لم نرى ولم
نشاهد اي رد فعل او انتقام كما توعدت
القيادات الروسيه بما حدث في المسيرات فوق
الكرملين منهم من قال انه استهداف
القيادات السياسيه حتى وصولا الى رئيس
اللنسكي حتى الان لم نشهد هذا الامر ونحن
نعرف ان كيا فيا مركز ثقل السياسي فاذا من
الطبيعي ان يكون الرد عليها هذا بالاضافه
الى بدء العمل بما بصواريخ الباتريوت
بطاريتين من المانيا وحتى من بولندا فيما
يتعلق بباخموت مؤسسه شركه فارغنري يقول
بانه بدا بتلقي الامدادات وانه كثف هجمات
هل الموضوع موضوع امدادات في باخم وت
هي امدادات خلافات خلافات بين فاقنر
القوات الشيشانيه خديروف وحتى مع القيادات
العسكريه من رئيس الاركان الذي هو قائد
العمليات العسكريه على المسرح الاوكراني
ومع وزير الدفاع والغريب في الامر انه لم
يؤخذ امر لحسم هذا الموضوع وهذا الامر
يعكس صوره سلبيه جدا جدا للجيش الاوكراني
وقد يمكن القول ان هناك عده جيوش تقاتل في
نفس الوقت شكرا لك العميد الياس حنا كنت
معنا من بيروت
[موسيقى]
الى ايران وفي الذكرى الخامسه لانسحاب
الرئيس الامريكي السابق من الاتفاق النووي
اكدت الخارجيه الايرانيه ان احياء الاتفاق
بشان البرنامج النووي يبقى ممكنا لكن
المتحدث باسم الخارجيات الايرانيه ناصر
كنعاني حمل افلام مؤتمر صحفيا الدول
الغربيه خصوصا الولايات المتحده مسؤوليه
التاخر في ذلك
هذا واكد متحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان الرئيس الامريكيه جو بايدن
ملتزم بعدم السماح لايران بحيازه سلاح
نووي واضاف في تصريحات للجزيره ان الاداره
الامريكيه لا تزال ترى ان الدبلوماسيه هي
الطريق الامثل للوصول الى ذلك الهدف مضيفا
ان واشنطن تبقي جميع الخيارات قائمه بشان
التعامل مع الملف النووي الايراني
مسار مفاوضات فيينا بشان الاتفاق النوويه
الايراني او خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه
مره بمراحل الشد وجذب منذ انسحاب الرئيس
الامريكي وشكلت ثقه بين الاطراف عامل
الحسم في امكانيه العوده الى الاتفاق
بصياغات جديده نستعرض ابرز محطات مفاوضات
الاتفاق النووي الايراني في تقرير لعبد
القادر عربه
في الثامن من مايو ايار 2018 اعلن الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب انسحاب
بلاده من الاتفاق واصدر اوامر التنفيذيه
اعاد بموجبها فرض العقوبات التي رفعت
بعدها بعام تماما اعلن الرئيس الايراني
السابق حسن الروحاني ان ايران ستتوقف عن
الامتثال لاجزاء من الاتفاق النووي بدات
معالم ذلك تظهر جليا الثاني قالت الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ان ايران خزنت
اليورانيوم بكميات تفوق المسموح بها 12
ضعفا انتخب بيضا رئيسا وفي يناير كانون
الثاني 2021 اكد امكانيه عوده بلاده
بالتشاور مع حلفائها الى الاتفاق النووي
في الاشهر الثلاثه الاولى من عام 2021
اتخذت ايران خطوات تضمنت تقييد عمل
المفتشين الدوليين ورفع التخصيب بدايه الى
20% ولاحقا الى 60% وفي اواخر تشرين
الثاني نوفمبر من العام نفسه استانفت
المباحثه
استهران عن اتفاق عادل وضمانات بعدم
التكرار الانسحاب الامريكي لكن الغزو
الروسيه لاوكرانيا القى بضلاله على
المباحثات ليعلن الاتحاد الاوروبي في مارس
اذار الحاجه الى تعليق المفاوضات بسبب
عوامل الخارجيه بدت مرتبطه بطرح روسيا
شروطا تتعلق بالعقوبات المفروضه عليها وفي
الثامن والعشرين من الشهر نفسه استضافه
الدوحه جوله من المباحثات غير المباشره
جمعت واشنطن وطهران برعايه من الاتحاد
الاوروبي واختتمت بعد يومين دون تحقيق
تقدم المرجو وفي السادس والعشرين من يوليو
تموز الماضي اعلن اقتراح مسوده نص جديد
لاحياء الاتفاق النووي محذرا من ازمه
نوويه خطيره في حال رفض الاتفاق بعد خمسه
اشهر على توقفها استانفت مفاوضات فيينا في
الرابع من اب اغسطس 2022 لكن جمودا في
مسار المفاوضات اوصل اطراف الحوار الى
طريق مسدود منذ الثامن من اغسطس من العام
الماضي وتوقفت معه امال احياء الاتفاق
النووي من جديد
راس العوده الى الاتفاق النووي ما بين
الشروط الايرانيه والموقف الامريكي سيكون
موضوع نقاشا اوسع بعد قليل في فقره في
المتابعه
[موسيقى]
نقلت وكاله رويتس عنا مصادر محليه
واستخباراتيه قولها ان الاردن نفذ ضربات
جويه نادره على جنوب سوريا استهدفت مصنع
مخدرات مرتبطا بايران وقتلت مهربا يزعموا
انه كان وراء عمليات شحن كبيره عبر حدود
البلدين من جانبه قال وزير الخارجيه
الاردني ايمن الصفدي ان قضيه تهريب
المخدرات من سوريا تشكل تهديدا كبيرا
للاردن والمنطقه
عندما نتخذ اي خطوه
لحمايه امننا الوطني ومواجهه اي تهديد له
سنعلنها في وقتها المناسب بالنسبه لقضيه
المخدرات كما اكدنا سابقا هو هي تهديد
كبير
للمملكه وللمنطقه وللعالم ايضا في ضوء
تصاعد عمليات تهريب المخدرات في اجتماع
عمان اشرنا الى هذا
اتفقنا مع اخوتنا في الحكومه السوريه
باننا سنشكل فريقا سياسيا
امنيا مشتركا لمواجهه هذا الخطر
هكذا مدير الاعلام العسكري في الجيش
الاردني على عقيد مصطفى الحياري قد قال ان
الجيش يخوض ما وصفها بالحرب على الحدود
الشماليه للبلاد لمواجهه الزياده الكبيره
في عمليه تهريب المخدرات
ما الذي يحدث على الحدود الشماليه
والشرقيه للمملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه هو ان
نشامى القوات المسلحه يواجهون حاليا
حرب على هذه الحدود حرب مخدرات
لدينا في
السنوات الاخيره
2020-2021
و2022 زياده كبيره
باضعاف بالنسبه لعمليات
محاولات وعمليات التسلل والتهريب وبشكل
رئيسي تهريب المخدرات
ينضم الينا من عمان سمير الحباشنه وزير
الداخليه الاردنيه السابقه اهلا بك يا سيد
سمير سيد سمير بدايه ما حجم الخطر التي
يتهدد الاردن من تهريب المخدرات من سوريا
والى اي مدى يمكن ان يصل مستوى الرد
قصه المخدرات
والتهريب وتهريب الممنوعات بشكل عام هذا
صداع للدوله الاردنيه منذ سنوات طويله لكن
بالتاكيد في الفتره الاخيره
وبغياب سيطره الدوله السوريه على مناطقها
المختلفه فقد اصبح الاردن في مجابهه حقيقه
عصابات
ضخمه مدججه ربما منظمه تسعى الى ادخال
المخدرات الاردن وبالتالي الى دول الاشقاء
في السعوديه والخليج العربي اعتقد ان
الاردن ياخذ هذه المعركه منذ سنوات
وبضراوه الجديد اليوم سيدتي ان الاردن
يقوم بعمليات داخل سوريا
وتقديري الشخصيه ان هذا الامر قد تم بعد
اجتماع عمان ولقاء وزراء الخارجيه الخمس
وتشكيل لجنه اردنيه امنيه سوريه واحده من
مضامينها هو اشتقاقاتها
انه يسمح للدوله الاردنيه والقوات المسلحه
الاردنيه ان تضرب في العمق السوري مواقع
المخدرات انا بعتقد انه تنسيق وهو من
ثمرات لقاء عمان ومن ثمرات عوده سوريا الى
الجامعه العربيه واعتقد انها خطوه متقدمه
في طريق ما سمي بالخطوه خطوه ان الاردن
يعني راس الحربه بان تعود العلاقات مع
الاشقاء السوريين بالتنسيق وفي واحده من
اهم هذه المسائل هي قصه المخدرات وقصه
مكافحه المخدرات حتى لو كانت داخل العمقي
السوري
هذا ما يفسر الاعلان عن هذه
الضربه يعني سابقا كان الجانب الاردني
وكما ذكرت ياخذوا حاربا ولكن لا يعلن عن
ذلك
صحيح الان احنا واضح تماما ان هذه المساله
بالتنسيق مع اخواننا في دمشق وان هناك
واضح في اراده للحكومتين الاردنيه
والسوريه بان ننتهي من موضوع المخدرات
والنكافح اليوم الجديد في الموضوع هو عوده
سوريا وهذا ما كنا وطالما هنا في الجزيره
نطالب به انه اذا اردنا ان ننسق الامور مع
الاشقاء السوريين فلا بد من التواصل معهم
والحمد لله قد تم والاشقاء العرب كلهم
بهذا الاتجاه واجتماع القاهره بالامس
واجتماع عمان بقبله واجتماع جدي قبل ذلك
كلها تدفع باتجاه ان يعود التنسيق بكل
المستويات واهم امر هو التنسيق الامني
وبالتالي مكافحه المخدرات كافه اجتماعيه
وامنيه تقلق الاردن وتقلق كل الدول
العربيه بلا
هل يعني ذلك ايضا بان هنالك المزيد من
الهجمات التي قد تنفذها او ينفذها الاردن
وتذهب ابعد من الحدود مع الجانب السوري
والله سيدتي هذا يبقى تقدير
لقواعد الاشتباك ولغرفه العمليات في
القوات المسلحه الاردنيه وفي التنسيق مع
الاشقاء السوريين لكن واضح باننا نذهب
خطوه اضافيه ونوعيه قلنا نقاومها من داخل
الحدود الاردنيه هافه المخدرات اليوم لا
الفضاء اوسع وبتقدير تصبح المهمه اسهل
علينا
بمكافحه هذه الافه والقضاء على كل من
يتاجر في المخدرات ويسير الانسان العربي
في كل الاقطار بما فيها سوريا بالمناسبه
اشرت الى التنسيق اكثر من مره طبيعه هذا
التنسيق مع الجانب السوري
كما ذكرت لك اعلن معالي وزير الخارجيه
بالمخرجات اللي صدرت عن الاجتماع
الوزراء الخارجيه الخمسه في عمان وحديث
الاستاذ الصفدي وزير الخارجيه بالامس بان
هناك اتفاقيه وتنسيق مع الحكومه السوريه
وشكلت اللجنه امنيه سياسيه واضح جدا لان
ما يجري اليوم هو نتاج هذه اللجنه الامنيه
السياسيه وقد تم ذلك بوجود وزير الخارجيه
السوري في عمان انا اعتقد الامور واضحه
سيدتي انا اعتقد ان الامور واضحه وايجابيه
وان شاء الله ننطلق على مرحله ابعد بتنسيق
مع اشقائنا السوريين كعرب شكرا لك سيد
سمير الحبشنه وزير الداخليه الاردنيه
السابقه كنت معنا من عمان
ينضم الينا من طهران الدكتور حسين روان
باحث متخصص في القضايا الاقليميه
والاستراتيجيه اسمع منك بدايه السيد
روبيران تعليق على ما نقلته وكاله رويترز
عن مصادر محليه بان ضربات جويه نادره
استهدفت مصنع مخدرات مرتبطا بايران داخل
سوريا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يعني في تصوري ان
في الوهله الاولى يعني هناك تعجب من ما
قامت به الحكومه السوريه
الاردنيه لماذا لان علاقات الاخوه مع
سوريا هي تفرض ان يكون هناك تنسيق ومعالجه
الامر من خلال الحكومه السوريه وليس نقض
السياده السوريه ومهاجمه الاراضي السوريه
في هذا الاطار واضح ان موضوع المخدرات هو
معضله في كل دول العالم وليس هناك من
استثناء في هذا الاطار وهناك ضروره في
معالجتها ولكن ما هو موجود الان في تصور
انه هناك سلوك يتماهى بشكل كبير مع الكيان
الصهيوني اسرائيل سوريا على خلفيه ان هناك
تهديد امني نعم يعني لو سمحت السيد الصفطي
وزير الخارجيه يتحدث عن تنسيق وانه نتاج
للقاءات التي جرت بين وزراء الخارجيه
وبينهم الجانب السوري
يعني لا استطيع ان اصدق ان هناك تنسيق
اردني سوري اللي نقض السياده السوريه
ومهاجمتها من خلال الطائرات الحربيه يعني
هذا موضوع لا يمكن لاي حكومه ان تقبل
وتطالب حكومه اخرى بنقض سيادتها ومهاجمه
اهداف في اراضيها الحكومه السوريه مسؤوله
نعم عن
معالجه هذا الموضوع ان وجد وفي تصوري يعني
ما اردت ان اقول ان ما تقوم به الاردن هو
يتشابه الى حد كبير مع ما تقوم باسرائيل
تقول ان هناك تهديد امني الان الاردن تطرح
تهديد اجتماعي دكتور حسين يعني اذا كان
الامر كذلك كيف تفسر عدم تعليق سوريا على
هذه الضربه على هذه الهجمه يعني الجانب
السوري لم يعلق عليها الا يدلل ذلك على
موافقه ضمنيه ان صح التعبير
لا اتصور ان ذلك يعني
سوريا
تعلن موقفها قطعا لحد الان ان لم تكن
اعلنت فهي ستعلن مستقبلا يعني هناك من
يريد اولا دعيني اشرح هذه النقطه يعني
بالتفصيل هناك من يريد ان يشوه الحضور
الاستشاري الايراني في سوريا
ويطرحه بشكل غير ما هو موجود ايران
استطاعت من خلال حضورها العسكري في سوريا
ان تدعم الحرب ضد الارهاب وان تفشل
المؤامره الامريكيه في فرض نظام جديد في
سوريا ولكن البعض يحاول ان يشوه هذه
الصوره المشرفه في الحرب ضد الارهاب الى
ان ايران تتعامل مع عصابات مخدرات الى
اخره وهذا في تصوري شيطنه ايران هي مؤامره
امريكيه اسرائيليه
تنخرط فيها بعض الدول الاخرى ما المصلحه
في هذا التوقيت لشيطنه ايران كما تقول
يعني الان سوريا تعود الى الجامعه العربيه
وهي مدعوه للحضور في يعني اجتماع القمه في
جده وفي تصوري ان الامور هي طبيعيه ولكن
من لا يرضى لهذه الامور ان تستمر من هنا
يحاول بشكل او باخر ان يقلب الطاوله من
خلال طرح اتهامات جديده لايران على خلفيات
جديده لتشويه صوره ايران وحلفاء سوريا
في الميدان هذا هو ما يعني
يحاول البعض ان يطرحه في الوقت الحاضر
شكرا لك الدكتور حسين وايران باحث متخصص
في القضايا الاقليميه والاستراتيجيه كنت
معنا من طهران
الان الى مشهد الانتخابات في تركيا
الى مشهد الانتخابات في تركيا حيث تواصلت
اليوم الحملات الانتخابيه للاحزاب
السياسيه في وقت بدا فيه العد العكسي
للانتخابات بعد سته ايام ففي مدينه قدرنا
شمال غربي البلاد خاطب الرئيس التركي
ومرشح وتحالف الجمهور رجب طيب اردوغان
مناصريه متهما منافسيح
منافسه كالجدار اوغلو بتلقي الدعم من من
سماهم قاده التنظيمات الارهابيه في اشاره
لحزب العمال الكردستاني وايضا بالحصول على
دعايه في الدول الغربيه
[موسيقى]
اما كلجد زعيم وحزب الشعب الجمهوري ومرشح
الطاوله السداسيه فقال انه يراهن على
الشباب التركي لصناعه التغيير في
الانتخابات المقبله واوضح في خطابه امام
انصاره في مدينه اضنه بالجنوب التركي ان
نحو خمسه ملايين شاب تركي سيمارسون حقهم
في الاقتراع لاول مره في هذه الانتخابات
مؤكدا انهم من سيدفع بالتغيير
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تتجه
الانظار الى الاجتماع المرتقب غدا
الثلاثاء في البيت الابيض بين الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن وقاده الكونجرس
الامريكي في محاوله للوصول الى اتفاق حول
رفع سقف الدين وتجنب تخلف الولايات
المتحده عن سداد ديونها ويطالب الجمهوريون
الرئيس بايدن بتخفيض النفقات عن بعض
المشاريع كشرط لرفع سقف الدين بينما يتمسك
بايدن برفع سقف الدين دون شروط كما جرت
العاده مع الادارات السابقه
ما لم يرفع الكونغرس سقف الدين العام
الامريكي خلال الشهر الحالي فان النتائج
ستكون كارثيه تحضير صريح وواضح من وزيره
الخزانه الامريكيه بشان ازمه الخلاف بين
البيت الابيض والجمهوريين في مجلس النواب
الامريكي
اولوياتنا هي ان يقوم الكونجرس بواجبه
ليست هناك طريقه اخرى لحمايه نظامنا
المالي واقتصادنا سوى ان يقوم الكونغرس
بعمله ويرفع سقف الدين العام كي نتمكن من
دفع المستحقات المترتبه علينا
الازمه تفجرت حين اشترط الجمهوريون قبولهم
رفع سقف الدين مقابل تقليص الانفاق في
المشاريع التي اقرتها اداره بايدن خلال
عامين من الحكم وقد عرضت الاغلبيه
الجمهوريه رؤيتها لتحقيق ذلك عبر مشروع
قرار تمكنت من تمريره في مجلس النواب رغم
معارضه اربعه جمهوريين وجميع النواب
الديمقراطيين المشروع يعرض رفع سقف الدين
بتريليون ونصف ترليون دولار مقابل عدول
اداره بايدن عن عدد من مشاريعها بل الغاء
بعض مما حققته من اجندتها المحليه مثل
اعفاءات القروض الطلابيه او تطوير وتحديث
وكاله تحصيل الضرائب الفيدراليه وحتى
حوافز التشجيع على التحول نحو موارد
الطاقه النظيفه شروط يرى فيها البيت
الابيض ابتزازا غير مقبول ياخذ اقتصاد
البلاد رهينه خدمه عمده حزبيه ضيقه ودعا
قاده الكونغرس من الحزبين للاجتماع معه في
البيت الابيض للوصول الى حل
الامور في واشنطن عاده لا تحل الا في
اللحظات الاخيره اعتقد ان بايدن كان يظن
انه سيظهر بدور البطل لعدم تفاوضه وسيظهر
الجمهوريين كالاشرار وهذا لم يحدث وبات
عليه ان يتنازل قليلا عن اجندته في حينما
كارث يخشى من ان يخسر رئاسه مجلس النواب
ان تعاون مع الديمقراطيين
هذا الاستعصاء ان استمر فستكون له اثار
خطيره للغايه على الاقتصاد الامريكي وعلى
النظام المالي العالمي برمته فعدم رفع سقف
الدين ستنتج عنه تداعيات تبدا بتخلف
الولايات المتحده عن سداد ديونها وتخفيض
التصنيف الائتماني للبلاد وانخفاض سعر
الدولار وتراجع الثقه به كاحتياطي نقدي
عالمي
تداعيات يخشى الخبراء ان تكون كارثيه ان
تعذر سد الفجوه بين اداره بايدن وخصومها
الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب خشيه مصحوبه
بامل التوصل الى توافق بعين اجتماع البيت
الابيض احمد هزيم الجزيره واشنطن
[موسيقى]
بالعوده الى ذكرى انسحاب الولايات المتحده
من الاتفاق النووي مع ايران فخلال خمس
سنوات ترى التحولات كبرى على مواقف طهران
وعلى ابحاثها النوويه ولا سيما حيازه
اليورانيوم كميه وتخصيبات ففي نوفمبر
الماضي اعلنت منظمه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه رسميا بدا تخصيب اليورانيوم
بنسبه 60% في منشات فوردو النوويه جنوب
البلاد وهذه النسبه من التخصيب تفوق بكثير
نسبه 3.67 التي ينص عليها الاتفاق النووي
الملغى من واشنطن من جانب واحد واستنادا
الى تقديرات الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه فقط زادت ايران مخزونها من
اليورانيوم ان نقي للانشطاري من نحو 55
كلغ ونصف الى اكثر من اثنين وستين كيلو
جراما كما يبدو واضحا هنا وتتهم الوكاله
طهران بتبديل اجهزه الطرد المركزي اي ار 1
في منشاه فوردو باخرى متطوره من نوع اي ار
6 وهو ما سيضاعف قدرات ايران على التخصيب
عشر مرات
ورغم مضيء تلك المده على الانسحاب
الامريكي من الاتفاق وفشل محادثات فيينا
لاحقا تؤكد ايران دوما رغبتها في احياء
الاتفاق لكن وفق شروط تراها ضروريه من
ابرزها
دفع دائم للعقوبات الاقتصاديه المفروض
عليها بما فيها القطاع النفطي ورفع
التجميد عن الودائع الماليه الايرانيه في
البنوك الغربيه والحصول على التكنولوجيا
لاسيما الطائرات المدنيه وقطع غيارها كما
تطالب طهران بما تسميه ضمانات موثوقه
لتحسين الاتفاق من اي قرار امريكي
بالتراجع عنه مستقبلا ومن تلك الضمانات
حمايه الشركات الاجنبيه من عقوبات واشنطن
من بين الشروط ايضا مطالبه طهران لو
واشنطن باستبعاد الحرس الثوري الايراني من
القائمه الامريكيه للمنظمات الارهابيه
الخارجيه المصنف ضمنها حول هذا الموضوع
ينضم الينا من طهران الدكتور عماد ابشنال
رئيس نقابه مراكز الابحاث والدراسات في
ايران كما ينضم الينا من واشنطن السفير بي
جي كراولي المتحدث السابق باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه ابدا معك دكتور عماد دكتور عماد
ما هي النقطه التي توقفت عندها
المفاوضات السابقه التي جرت في فيينا
وكانت الامال معقوده بانها تحرز تقدما
تحياتي لك لضيف العزيز والمشاهدين الكرام
في الواقع وصل الجميع الى مسوده اتفاق في
شهر مارس من العام الماضي
وتقرر ان يتم التوقيع على هذه المسوده بعد
انتخابات الكونغرس الامريكي ولكن للاسف
عودتنا الولايات المتحده دوما من انها لا
تقوم بتنفيذ تعهداتها يعني هذه المره ايضا
الولايات المتحده بعد الانتخابات الكونجرس
تراجعت عن
تعهداتها بان يتم التوقيع على هذه الاتفاق
المسوده
ولربما اتصور السبب انهم كانوا يتصورون ان
الاحتجاجات في ايران ممكن ان تسمح لهم
بكسب اوراق اكثر في هذه المفاوضات وكانوا
ينتظرون كي يروا ان كان بامكانهم ان
يحصلوا على هذه الا بعد ان انتهت
الاحتجاجات وبعد ان فشلوا في مؤامراتهم ضد
ايران هم عادوا يعني يعني يبحثون في من
خلال الاوروبيين في اعاده
تفعيل
المفاوضات
مجددا وايراما زالت تسر على ان الوسوده
الاتفاق الذي تم التوصل الى موجوده اذا ما
ارادوا
يمكن العوده
ثلاث ملاحظات على هذه المسوده ما هي هذه
الملاحظات
ليس هناك ملاحظات كبيره جدا يعني عمليا
ايران تصر ما زالت تصر على الضمانات التي
يجب ان يقوم الاوروبي او الامريكي تقديمها
كي لا تعود الولايات المتحده مستقبلا
بالخروج من الاتفاق النووي
ثانيا موضوع اليورانيوم المخصب واجهزه
الطرد المركزي
يعني كان وفق لهذا الاتفاق مسوده الاتفاق
يجب ان يتم نقله الى روسيا بعد الحرب في
اوكرانيا الامريكي اصار على ان لا يتم
نقله الى روسيا
وليس هناك اي بلد اخر تثق فيه ايران لكي
يتم نقل هذا اليورانيوم على هذا الاساس
تصل ايران على الابقاء على اجهزه الطرد
المركزي
اليورانيوم في داخل ايران في مخازن مقفوله
بالشمع الاحمر من قبل المنظمه الدوليه
للطاقه وفي حال خرجت الولايات المتحده من
الاتفاق النووي او تنصلت عن تنفيذ
تعهداتها يحق لايران ان تخرج اليورانيوم
وتستمر من حيث انتهت سيد بيجي كراولي يعني
اسمع منك تعليق على ما ذكره الدكتور عماد
وهل العوده لاحياء الاتفاق النووي لا تزال
ممكنه
بكل اسف لا اعتقد ان احياء خطه العمل
الشامله المشتركه ممكرا في هذه المرحله من
الزمن وكما اشار الضيف الاخر وكما تم
الاشاره في المقدمه هناك مساء المتعدده
مرتبطه
بالملاحظات التي كانت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه على هذا الاتفاق واوضحت من خلال
الوصيه الاوروبي للفريق التفاوضي الايراني
نحن نتحدث عن اتفاق سياسي وليست معاهده
رسميه وبالتالي مساله الضمانات هي المساله
الاساسيه لا يمكن هذا الرئيس ان يلزم
الرئيس المستقبلي في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بهذا الاتفاق الرئيس اوباما
تفوض بنيه حسنه الرئيس ترامبون سحب من
الاتفاق وبكل تاكيد هذا ممكن في المستقبل
ولكن المعلوم ان هنالك استمراريه في
الاتفاقات التي تعق الدول والا ما جدوى
عقد اتفاق اذا كان كل رئيس يعني سينسحب من
هذا الاتفاق ويعود اليه كما يشاء
في الحقيقه بالنسبه الي الخساره الكبير
الناتجه عن قرار اداره بالانسحاب من خطه
العمل الشامله المشتركه كانت انها ادت الى
الحق الضرر بقنوات اتصال تم تطويرها بين
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ووزاره الخارجيه
الايرانيه وهذه القناه قامت اساسيه
للعلاقات الدبلوماسيه انذاك ووزير
الخارجيه
كان على تواصل مع وزير الخارجيه السيد
ظريف وكان هناك اتصال بين الرجلين عندما
كان منسوب التوتر يرتفع بين البلدين
والرجلان توصل الى حلول لذلك خطه العمل
الشامله المشتركه لطالما تم النظر اليها
على انها خط اساسيه على المسار الصحيح
لاداره علاقه صعبه بين الطرفين ومن
الصعوبه مكان وبالنظر الى ما حصل في فيينا
الجانب الايراني رفض ان يجلس بشكل مباشر
ويتفاوض مع الفريق الامريكي وبالتالي لسوء
الحظ لا نرى طرقا عمليه لاعاده او للعوده
الى خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه حتى انه
في هذه المرحله ما من سبل عمليه تؤدي الى
خفض منسوب التوتر في العلاقه بين الولايات
المتحده وايران وهذا خطر كبير
اتفاق امر ممكن ولكن كيف ايران اليوم ليست
ايران الامس يعني ايران خصبت اليورانيوم
بنسب اعلى ولديها مخزون اكبر اذا كيف يمكن
العوده الى ذاك الاتفاق
يعني انا اوافق سعد السفير على ما قاله
بالنسبه لان الاتفاق النووي كان ممكن ان
يكون
بادره لحل العديد من الخلافات بين ايران
والولايات المتحده او حتى حل الخلافات
الدوليه على اساس
الدبلوماسيه وليس عبر الدخول الى الحروب
اليوم الاتفاق النووي انا اتصور ما زال
بالامكان احيائه اذا ما كان هناك اراده من
قبل الولايات المتحده كي تقوم بتن بالعوده
الى الاتفاق النووي وتقوم بتنفيذه للاسف
اليوم نحن نواجه اداره ضعيفه متردده في
خطواتها او تصرفاتها ولهذا فاننا لا نصل
الى نتيجه اريد ان اسمع من السفيره بيجي
كراولي سيد كراولي يعني ما الذي حققته
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من الانسحاب
من هذا الاتفاق اير ان لديها مخزون اعلى
من اليورانيوم المخصب وخاصه بنسب اعلى ما
الذي حققته الولايات المتحده
في الحقيقه يمكنني ان اقول تحقق القليل كي
لا اقول لم يتحقق اي شيء انا ذاك الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب ان حمله الضغط الاقصى
يمكن ان تعود بايران الى طاوله المفاوضات
وفقا لهذه الشروط والعوده الى خطه العمل
الشامله المشتركه بالنسبه الى هذا الاتفاق
كان متاحا في تلك المرحله وهو كان افضل
الممكن في تلك المرحله وحصل الكثير في
خلال السنوات الماضيه انا افهم التشكيك
الايراني في العوده الى المفاوضات ظنا بان
الرئيس المستقبلي في الولايات المتحده قد
يعود وينسحب من الاتفاق هذا وجيه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ايضا هناك
المتحدث السابق باسم الخارجات الامريكيه
شكرا وعذرا على المقاطعه دعمنا الوقت من
طهران الدكتور عماد رئيس نقابه مراكز
الابحاث والدراسات فعلا
مستمدون معكم في جوله الحصاد واليكم
تذكيرا بابرز العناوين
تصاعد حده المعارك والاشتباكات في الخرطوم
قوات الدعم السريع تقول انها تحاصر مقر
القياده العامه والجيش يشن غارات على
مواقع لها ومع استمرار محادثات جدا بين
طرفي النزاع البرهان يؤكد جاهزيته لاي
مبادره تنهي النهب والتخريب في البلاد
والمتحدث باسم الاتحاد الافريقي بشان
السودان يؤكد للجزيره بدلا المنظمه جهودا
اقليميه ودوليه لمنع نشوب حرب اهليه
وسط ترقب للهجوم الاوكراني المضاد قائد
فاجنر يؤكد تلقيه امدادات عسكريه وبدا
هجوم مكثف في باخموت والقوات الروسيه توسع
موجه ضرباتها على كييف ومدن اخرى وعشيه
احتفالات روسيا بذكرى النصر على النازيه
تخوف اوكراني من هجوم واسع النطاق غدا
وبعد خمس سنوات على انسحاب الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب من الاتفاق
النبوي جمود مستمر في مسار فيينا التفاوضي
ايران تقول ان احياء الاتفاق امر ممكن
وتحذر من اي استهداف لمصالحها القوميه
ومتحدث باسم الخارجات الامريكيه يقول
للجزيره ان واشنطن تتمسك بنهج الدبلوماسيه
وانها ستمنع ايران من امتلاك سلاح النووي
[موسيقى]
تصاعد مستوى المعارك والاشتباكات في
السودان حيث سمعت الانفجارات في الخرطوم
مع تصاعد اعمده الدخان في محيط القصر
الجمهوري وبحسب مراسلنا فان المضادات
الارضيه التابعه للدعم السريع ردت على
طلعات جديده للجيش في الخرطوم بحري ياتي
ذلك مع استمرار محادثات ممثلين عن الطرفين
في مدينه جده السعوديه وهي مباحثات اكدت
قوه الدعم السريع اقتصارها على الهدنه
والجوانب الانسانيه بينما نقلت وكاله
الصحافه الفرنسيه عن دبلوماسيا سعوديا
قوله انها لم تحرز تقدما كبيرا حتى الان
مؤكدا ان الوقف الدائم لاطلاق النار ليس
مطروحا وان كل جانب يعتقد انه قادر على
حسم المعركه
هذا واكد فيدان تبديل نائب المتحدث باسم
الخارجات الامريكيه انخراط بلاده في جهود
التوصل الى وقف اطلاق النار في السودان
وعرب بتيل عن تقدير واشنطن لدوري السعوديه
في تسهيل المحادثات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع
نحن منخرطون بعمق في ضمان التوصل لوقف
اطلاق النار في السودان ونرحب ببدء
المفاوضات بين القوات المسلحه وقوات الدعم
السريع كما نقدر دور السعوديه في استضافه
هذه المباحثات طرفا الصراع يراجعان
اقتراحا بحمايه مدنيين وتسهيل الاعمال
الانسانيه ونواصل اشراك القاده المدنيين
للعمل نحو اقامه حكم ديمقراطي مدني باسرع
وقت ممكن ونعتقد ان تلك هي اراده الشعب
السوداني
ينضم الينا من جنوب الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره
محمد الطيب ومن واشنطن مراسل جزيره عبد
الفتاح فايد ابدا معك محمد مع ما سجلته
الساعات الاخيره من مستجدات على المستوى
الميداني وايضا سياسيا كيف ينظر الى ما
يجري في جده
لعلنا نبدا بالمستجدات الميدانيه في
الواقعه الان يسود هدوء حذر معظم اعصاء
معظم مناطق العاصمه الخرطوم بعد ان شهدت
اشتباكات ساخنه استخدمت فيها المدفعيه
الثقيله في وسط العاصمه وفي محيط القصر
الرئاسي
وايضا الطيران كان قد حلق في مناطق شمبات
وفي بحري لكن بعد هذه الساعات نحو اربع
ساعات او ثلاث ساعات من الان الهدوء هو
السيد الموقف هناك حدود حذر في هذه
المناطق لم نعد نسمع في الواقع بشكل اشكال
الاشتباكات او اطلاق النار او المضادات
الطيران في هذا التوقيت بالذات معظم فيما
يتعلق بالمسار السياسيه
والنظر الى الوساطه والمفاوضات الموجوده
في جده كانت عدد من القوى السياسيه رحبت
بهذه الوساطه واعتبرتنا انها شكل من اشكال
الخروج من الازمه الحاليه ودعت فيها طرفي
الصراع الجاه القوات المسلحه السودانيه
قوات الدعم السريع الى الاحتكام الى صوت
العقل والى ايقاف
الاقتتال والوصول الى حل سلمي فيما يتعلق
بهذه الازمه عدد من الاحزاب السياسيه من
بينها
الحزب السوداني علق رئيسه
كان في تغريده نشرها قبل نحو نصف ساعه من
الان تحدث عن ان المفاوضات في جده هي
الفرصه المواتيه والجيده للوصول الى اتفاق
فيما يتعلق بهذا الامر الشارع السوداني
هنا ينظر الى هذه
المفاوضات ويعقد عليها امالا في ان تخفف
عليهم المخاوف التي يعيشونها يوميا بفعل
القصف وبفعل الاشتباكات والمظاهر المسلحه
في عدد من شوارع الخرطوم وبالتالي هم
يريدون ان تفضي الى شكل من اشكال
الاستتباب الامن قدرتهم على الحركه من
والى مناطق اخرى قضاء احتياجاتهم الوصول
المستشفيات والقدره على الحصول على المال
الذي يحتاجونه لقضاء حواجههم بصوره العامه
رغم ان هذه المفاوضات حتى الان لم تخرج
بجديد لكن ما زالت هناك امال كبيره يعني
منعقده على هذه المفاوضات ان تخرج بشيء
جيد قد يقلل الاحتقان ويقلل المخاوف لكثير
من المواطنين الذين باتت العاصمه بالنسبه
لهم يعني مكانا غير امن وعدد كبير منه
محاوله الخروج والذين بقوا في بيوتهم ما
زالوا يعني يعانون من ظروف الانسانيه صعبه
ابقوا معنا انتقل اليك عبد الفتاح يعني هل
تبدو الولايات المتحده الامريكيه متفائله
بهذه المحادثات
اولا هذه المحادثات هي تاتي بناء على
المبادره الامريكيه السعوديه وفقا لما اقر
به الجيش السوداني واطراف الصراع في
السودان وبالتالي السلطات الامريكيه
والاداره الامريكيه تقول انها تعمل
باستمرار وباتصالات مكثفه وبجهود متواصله
على وقف هذا الصراع العسكري في السودان
لان هذا الصراع ليس فقط يضر بالوضع
الداخلي السوداني ولا يضر حتى بانع
الاقليم ولكنه يضر ايضا وفقا للبيان الذي
صدر عن البيت الابيض وعن الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن يضر بالامن القومي الامريكي
وبالمصالح العليا الامريكيه وبالسياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه في ظل ما باتي يعرف
بيت صراع النفوذ الدولي الان في السودان
والتحذيرات المتزايده من امكانيه ان يتوسع
هذا الصراع الى دول الجوار التي تعاني من
توترات واضطرابات سياسيه وامنيه في معظم
وصفت حالتها بانها هشه وايضا في ظل
المخاوف من وجود نفوذ دولي وصراع دولي
واقليمي في السودان على خلفيه هذا الصراع
العسكري وبالتالي الاداره الامريكيه تقول
انها تعمل باستمرار على انهاء هذا الصراع
على وقف اطلاق نار دائم ومستدام في الصراع
ولا في السودان وليس فقط مجرد هدنه تقول
ان هذه الهدنه التي تنتزعها
الاداره الامريكيه من خلال اتصالاتها مع
طرفه الصراع من جهه ومع الشركاء
الاقليميين والدوليين من جهه اخرى كما
تقول هي افضل من استمرار الوضع بدون هدنه
لانه حتى مع الخروقات في هذه الهدنه لكن
تشهد اعمال عنف اقل يكون هناك خفض في
اعمال العنف تسمح على الاقل للحالات
الانسانيه وتسمح بالمساعدات الانسانيه
وتسمح للمدنيين ايضا بالتزود باحتياجاتهم
على اق التقدير الخارجيه الامريكيه اليوم
كانت صريحه للغايه اكدت انها تدعم هذه
المفاوضات بقوه وتامل ان تسفر عن وقف دائم
ومستدام لاطلاق النار اشادت طبعا بالجهد
السعودي خاصه واننا نعلم ان البعثه
الامريكيه
الدبلوماسيه هي تقوم بشكل مكثف بعملها من
الاراضي السعوديه من جهه وايضا من خلال
اعاده موضوعها في بورسودان بعد تجميد
عملها في الخرطوم عبد الفتاح فايد مراسل
جزيره من واشنطن كما نشكر ايضا محمد الطيب
مراسل جزيره من جنوب الخرطوم
في لقاء اجريناها معه خلال الساعات الساعه
الاولى من الحصاد قال محمد
المتحدث باسم الاتحاد الافريقي بشان
السودان ان الامر المستعجل الان هو وقف
القتال وتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه
للمحتاجين ما سيسمح باستئناف المسار
السياسي واكد للجزيره بدله المنظمه جهودا
اقليميه ودوليه لمنع نشوب حرب اهليه
بطبيعه الحال لابد من البحث لحل للازمه
لان الصراع في السودان اذا لم يتم حل حلا
عقلانيا وجديا فان هذا البلد العظيم
والشعب العظيم قد يضيعان وقد يتلفان كل
المنطقه
الحساسه في افريقيا والعالم وبالتالي من
اجل ان يعاد مسار الحل السياسي لابد من
يقف على الاقتتال وهذا الناس المتضرره من
الحرب ولكن لا يمكن باي حال من الاحوال ان
تتوقف الامور على وقف اطلاق النار
والاعادات الانسانيه هذه امور مستعجله
وشرط
لاعاده المسار السياسي
ينضم الينا لواء معتصم عبد القادر حسن
المستشار في الاكاديميه العليا للدراسات
الامنيه والاستراتيجيه لواء معتصم يعني
هنالك تحذيرات من ان تؤدي هذه المواجهه
الى ضياع السودان هل يؤخذ ذلك في عين
الاعتبار من قبل الاطراف المتواجهه
[موسيقى]
اولا الحديث عن اي حرب اهليه في السودان
هذه غير وارده اطلال لان الان القوات
المسلحه السودانيه تسيطر على 17 ولايه من
18 ولايه والبنايه الاخيره هي ولايه
الخرطومات المليشيا المتمرده تسيطر على
بعض المرافق المدنيه والحيويه وهنالك
سيطر جزئيه على المطار وعلى القصر
الجمهوري وعلى جزء من القياده العامه
والقوات المسلحه الثنائي تعمل على اخراجها
من هذه الاماكن ولكن وفقا لخطه مدروسه تضع
في اعتبارها عدم حدوث خسائر وسط المدنيين
ووسط المرافق العامه والخاصه هذا هو لذلك
اي حديث على ان هناك حرب اهليه او قبليه
يمكن ان تنشا في السودان هذه مساله غير
وارده اطلاقا لان مناط حتى مناطق التي
تنتمي اليها اغ هذه المليشيا المتورده
الان في امن وفي اغراض اما الحديث عن ان
يمتد الصراع خارج السودان هذا الصراع يعني
هنالك قوه ساعدت هذه الميليشيا المتمرده
وتم تحشيد
الدول السودان خصوصا للدول السلاح الى
الافريقي على اعتقد ان هذه المدرسه سوف
تعود على لان قطعا سيتم دحر هذه القوه
وتعود الى مناطقها الاساسيه وتشكل وتزعزع
للامن والاستقرار في الساحل الافريقي
يعني ساعود معك الى التدخلات الخارجيه وما
تقصدون بذلك ولكن عندما تحدثتم عن خطه
وضعها الجيش من اجل استعاده بعض الاماكن
التي يسيطر عليها الدعم السريع ذكرتم
بانها تاخذ بعين الاعتبار الخسائر البشريه
ولكن اليوم هنالك العشرات من القتلى
السودانيين هنالك
ايضا عدد كبير من المصابين هنالك توقف
للعديد من المرافق العامه ما يهدد حياه
السودانيين منها المستشفيات بالاضافه الى
الكثير من من خرجوا خارج البلاد سعيا
لمناطق اكثر امنا
نعم هذه نعم هنالك خسائر وسط المدنيين
وهذه الحرب بالذات الخسائر وسط المدنيين
كبيره اكثر من الخسائر الوسطى القوات
المسلحه الخسائر وسط المدنيين ووسط القوات
المتمرده لان هذه القوات داهمت القوات
المسلحه على حين غره
ان تستوي على المناطق السريعه
القوات المسلحه الصدمه الاولى وتعاملت
معها بطريقه احترافيه الان هذه القوات
محاصره سيد عبد القادر لانك ذكرت ذلك قبل
ان لكي نستفيد من الوقت ما الذي تاملونه
من محادثات جده
هذه الهدنه تتطلب ان تخرج هذه المليشيا
المتواجده من المستشفيات ومن مساكن
المواطنين ومن المرافق العامه مثل
الكهرباء والمياه وخلافه والاتصالات هذه
هي المساله الاساسيه التي ويجب ان تضع هذه
المليئه سلاحها ارضا وجانبا كي تعود
الحياه الى طبيعتها
هذه المليشه كما كانت من قبل جزء من
القوات المسلحه هذه مساله تم التعامل معه
وتم حل هذه المليشيا شكرا لك معتصم عبد
القادر حسن اللواء معتصم عبد القادر حسن
المستشار في الاكاديميه العليا للدراسات
الامنيه والاستراتيجيه شكرا لك
حول نفس الموضوع ينضم الينا من الخرطوم
حافظ كبير الكاتب والمحلل السياسي سيد
حافظ اذا يعني ما يدعو اليه الجيش
السوداني واضح وخروج قوات الدعم السريع من
المرافق العامه مقابل ضمان سلامه هؤلاء هل
يمكن ان يوافق ان توافق قوات الدعم
السريعه على ذلك
اهلا انا اعتقد ان هذا هذا الطلب غير
موضوع وهو بالاساس
يعني
شروط قوي كانه هناك
منتصر هناك محزومه بالتالي المنتصر يفرض
شروطه ويعد عدم يعني الايداع او عدم
التعرض للمهزوم هذا غير صحيح نحن الان في
خضم معركه ما تزال
القوى وتدعم صامده
وتنتشر في اماكن واسعه يعني بخلاف الاماكن
والخادميه التي يتحدث عنها البعض ولم
يتعرض لها احد ولم يخرجها من هذه الاماكن
احد فبالتالي الحديث هو حديث لدر
استلطاف المواطن وكذلك يعني حديث للادانه
والمزايده اكثر منه حديث يعني جدي
مصلحه المواطن لان التي تقصف المصانع
والمنازل ليس هناك يعني قوات دعم في هذه
الاماكن وانما يعني تواصل
ما السبيل للخروج من هذه الدائره المفرغه
يعني كل جهه تقول بانها هي صامده وهي من
تحقق انتصارات على الارض بغض النظر عن ذلك
كيف يمكن الخروج من هذا المازق الذي يعيشه
السودان مواجهات ادت الى خسائر بشريه تعطل
الدوله السودانيه مخاوف من يؤدي ذلك الى
ضياع السودان
ون حاله حرب
ليستمر لاكثر من 15 يوم وبالتالي
حاره الحرب السودان جربها من قبل وبالتالي
الخروج منها عبر التفاوض في الملفات كلها
في القبائل التي ادت الى الحرب وليست
قضايا التي نتجت عن الحرب
العقل يقول بان بانك عندما تدخل في حاله
حرب وهناك اثار جانبيه للحرب وتريد دري
هذه الاثاق او وقفها يكون هناك تصور لوقف
الحرب في مخاطبه الاسباب الجذريه بالحرب
وكذلك بمخاطبه الاثار التي تركب على الحرب
لكن ان يقول الجيش بانه فقط يناقش الاثار
التي تركته على الحرب مع الطرف مع الطرف
الذي يخاف معه حرف ويترك سبب الرئيسي هذا
امر غير مقبول وغير معقول حتى وبالتالي
المخرج هو المفاوضات الجلديه التي تفضي
الى حل الازمه السياسيه وحل لقضايا التي
كذلك ما الذي يدفع قوات الدعم السريع
للقبول بالمحادثات
الحلول العسكريه وبالتالي هي ليست فقط
لمناقشه القضيه
الاسلاميه كمرحله الاولى وكذلك
سياسيه التي اختلف من في مرحله ثانيه
تحدد
ويقول هناك
كبير الصوت يصل متقطعا ولا تصل الفكره
بشكل واضح شكرا لك الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
كنت معنا من الخرطوم
وفي ظل المواجهات المستمره يواجه اكثر من
سته الاف سوري اوضاعا انسانيه صعبه في
ميناء بورت سودان بعد فرارهم من المعارك
التي اندلعت بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع وتاخر عمليات اجلائهم
في معنى اطفال في
معنى المسلمين ما تنشال امه الله كلها
تطلع وتصير ببيوتا ونحن هون كثر خير اهل
بورسودان اللي عم يساعدونا وحطوا لنا
هذا الكلام يعني
كله كل العالم يصير ادبي بيوته ونعنا هون
قاعدين عم نستنى يعني شو نحن حجر ناقص
بدنا نرجع على بلدنا يا عمي حكومه العوده
الى دفيء الاهل والديار حلم يراود عشرات
السوريين الذين ينتظرون قرب ميناء
انهم يناشدون العالم سرعه تدخل للمساعده
في اجلائهم
الهندي اخذوه لاستراليا ياخذوه الكندي
بتبعث له طياره خاصه الهولندي شخص واحد
سفروه فورا من دون حتى مرته مع الجنسيه
الكنديه
العالم كله بتفهم بحقوق الانسان وبتلعب في
شعبها الا نحن نحن شو عاملين غلط للعالم
لحكومتنا للامه الاسلاميه لامه لا اله الا
الله معقول امه المليار ما فيها تجلي 2000
شخص
نساء واطفال وعجزه فاجاتهم الحرب ورسمت
على واقعهم فصلا جديدا من معاناه لم تنتهي
اكثر من سته الاف من رعايا سوريا بمدينه
بورسودان ينتظرون اجلائهم منذ نحو ثلاثه
اسابيع
حتى الان الاعداد بازدياد تقدر تقول انه
نقص حوالي 350 شخص منذ اسبوعين لحد الان
لكن بالنسبه للعدد الكبير الاشياء هضمه
ملاحظه حتى اللحظه حصلت للاسف حاله وفاه
مذي يومين لامراه طاعنه بالسن لديها امراض
مزمنه ضغط وسكري لكن مفارقه الحياه بسبب
سوء الاوضاع المعيشي على الميناء
لم يعد لهؤلاء ما يكفي من مصروفات وهم
ينتظرون ما يقدم من غذاء وماء كمساعدات
فانتظار السوريين قرب ميناء بورسودان دون
اجلائهم حتى الان والى ان ياتيهم الفرج
ليس امامهم سوى مزيد من الانتظار في ظروف
انسانيه صعبه
وسام سيدي احمد الجزيره بورسودان
[موسيقى]
الى اوكرانيا حيث تعود العاصمه كيافه الى
واجهه الاحداث كهدف ابرز للقصف الروسي
المتواصل منذ ايام على العاصمه ومدن اخرى
في البلاد هذا وتتخوف الاداره الاوكرانيه
من تلقي هجوم كبير غدا تزامنا مع احتفالات
موسكو بيوم النصر على النازيه ياتي ذلك في
وقت يتزايد فيها الحديث عن الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد خلال هذا الشهر
اعتقد سكان العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف ان
الحرب ابتعدت عنهم لاشهر كانت سماء
العاصمه هادئه لا يعكر صفوها ضجيج الحرب
المستعره في الجنوب والشرق لكن اسراب
الطائرات المسيره غيرت هذا الواقع في وقت
وجيز 60 طائره مسيره هجمت العاصمه خلال
يوم واحد في هجوم هو الاكبر من نوعه بحسب
عمده المدينه كما اعلن الجيش الاوكراني ان
روسيا هاجمت المقاطعات الجنوبيه من
زبروجيا ودينيبرو شرقا الى اوديسا غربا
مرورا بميكولايف وخلص وسط البلاد بمختلف
انواع الاسلحه من غارات جويه وقذائف
صاروخيه اما على جبهه باخموت فتتحدث هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه عن صد 50 هجوم صاروخيا
واتهمت موسكو باستعمال القذائف الحارقه
وماده الفوسفور الابيض المحرم استعمالها
دوليا ضد المدنيين
التي تستمر المحاولات الروسيه للسيطره
عليها رغم ما يبدو من خلافات وانتقادات
للجيش الروسي من قوه فاجنر اما فخاركيف
فاعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه استعمال
قاذفات استراتيجيه لقصف من قالت انهم
مرتزقه اجانب كما قالت انها دمرت مجموعتين
اوكرانيتين في مقاطعه
القصف الروسي واستهداف كبرى المدن
الاوكرانيه
ان الاسوء لم يحدث بعد حيث تتداول على
اعلى المستويات في كييف انباء عن هجمات
اشد ستستهدف اوكرانيا بالتزامن مع ذكرى
النصر على النازيه التي تحتفل بها روسيا
في التاسع من مايو ايار
لا نعرف لماذا تشن كل هذه الهجمات الضخمه
في شهر مايو ومن الصعب للغايه تحليل سلوك
العدو وان كان لا يمكننا التاكد من الهدف
الذي وجهت اليه الطائرات بدون طيار الا
اننا نفترض انه من الممكن ان تكون مراكز
صنع القرار من بين تلك الاهداف حيث انهم
صرحوا مرارا وتكرارا انه بعد الضربات على
البنيه التحتيه ستكون مراكز صنع القرار هي
الهدف وفي بيان اللافت تحدث الجيش
الاوكراني عن انسحاب قيادات روسيه من مقر
وادارات يسيطرون عليها في خرسون باتجاه
شبه جزيره القرم واضاف البيان ان القوات
الاوكرانيه رصدت انسحابا مماثل في مدن
ومناطق خاضعه للسيطره الروسيه في المقاطعه
الجنوبيه
في بخمه قال مؤسس شركه ايفاجنر ان مجموعته
بدات بتلقي الامدادات العسكريه بعد انقطاع
وانها كثفت هجماتها لفرض السيطره على
المدينه ياتي ذلك بوقت قال فيه متحدث باسم
القياده الشرقيه الاوكرانيه ان الروس
يواصلون محاولاتهم للسيطره على مدينه
باخموت شرقي البلاد وان قوات فاجنر تعاني
من خسائر بشريه كبيره
ينضم الينا من اكياف الدكتور ايفان اوس
كبير الباحثين في المعهد الاوكراني
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه ومن موسكو الكسندر
الخبير العسكري والمختص في شؤون الناتو
ابدا مع الدكتور ايفان دكتور ايفان كيف
تلقت اكياد الرساله باستهداف العاصمه
الاوكرانيه بهذا الهجوم الكبير من
المسيرات
مساء الخير من كيف
ترحب بكم في استوديو وبالضيف من موسكو
وبجميع المشاهدين هذه ليست اول هجمه على
كيف
واصبحت هذه الهجمات شيء معتاد عليه في
البدايه كانت روسيا تهاجم العاصمه بمرات
كثيره ليس بالمسيرات فقط ولكن ثلاث ايام
سيد
ايفان بعد فتره من الهدوء هجوم بهذا الحجم
على العاصمه الاوكرانيه ما دلالاته
الان
قبيل التاسع من مايو في روسيا هناك حذر ان
اوكرانيا سوف تحاول ان تهاجم موسكو اثناء
المهرجان وهذه الهجمات هي محاوله للضغط
على اوكرانيا حتى لا يكون اي اعمال من هذا
النوع لذلك لو كان هناك اي شيء مخطط من
الجانب الاوكراني سوف يحدث في جميع
الاحوال وهم يعتقدون ان هذه هجمات توقف اي
شيء من هذا النوع لذلك كان هناك 35 مسيره
هاجمت العاصمه وكان كذلك
هجمات ضد ميناء اوديسا بالصواريخ ايضا
وحسب المعلومات هناك ضحيه واحده وايضا كان
هناك صاروخ اصابه مستودعا للصليب الاحمر
يحمل مساعدات لاوديسا
بعض المنشات التي اؤكد هذه الهجمات ليست
الاولى من نوعها وكان هناك الكثير من
الهجمات بالصواريخ عدا عن ذلك مسلسل ثلاث
ايام كان هناك هجمات بصواريخ الكنجاوي
الفرد صوتيه التي كان يعتقد انها من
المستحيل اسقاطها ولكنني لاول مره في
التاريخ استطاعت اوكرانيا اسقاط هذا
الصاروخ وهذا حادث غير مسبوق في التاريخ
العالمي لذلك لا استطيع ان اقول ان هناك
شيء جديد في هذه
الهجمات ضد العاصمه سيد ارتنوف هل هذا هو
الهدف من الهجوم الكبير والواسع على
العاصمه اكياف هل هو ايرباك احداث ايرباك
على نطاق السياسيه والاستراتيجي داخل
اوكرانيا
مسائكم طيب وارحب بالجميع وبالضيف من كيف
واستطيع ان اقول انني انظر لما حدث على
انه رد جزئي على الهجمات التي حدثت من قبل
اوكرانيا واعني هنا الهجمات
بمسييرتين على الكرملين
وكلى المسيرتين اسقطتا وهذا كان تحدي كبير
لان
المركز في كيف حيث اتخاذ القرارات لانه
نهاجم اي مباني رسميه حتى الان
ولذلك اعتقد ان هذه اعمال عسكريه صعبه
ولا استطيع ان افسر ما حدث باي طريقه اخرى
اما من جانب
الحذر ان كيف قد تقوم باي اعمال في اثناء
المهرجان ان كيف تقوم بهذا بشكل مستمر على
سبيل المثال رئيس المخابرات والامن
بلداننا قال انه سوف يبحث عن المسؤولين
الروس في كل العالم ويحاول الانتقام منهم
وهذا ما قاله رئيس
عفوا وزير الدفاع
لذلك هذه العمليه
هذه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه جاريه
واوكرانيا سوف تحولها الى حرب واسعه نحن
نقترب الى نهايه المواجهات ونريد ان
نستخدم كل وسائل الموجوده لدينا
وعندما عندما تقول بانه هذا رد جزئي
على ما تعرض له الكريم ما الذي يمكن ان
تفعله روسيا اكثر هنالك تصعيد للهجمات من
زباروجيا ودينبرو شرقا الى اوديسا غربا
مرورا بميكو لايف وخيرسون وسط البلاد يعني
وبالاضافه الى ما جرى في اكياف اذا ماذا
يمكن اكثر
اتفهم هذا السؤال كبير يجب ان اكون موضوعي
وانا لا اريد ان ادخل العاطفه ممكن ان
تقوم روسيا بامور لم يسبق لها القيام بها
لدينا ما يزيد عن الف صاروخ اسكاندير ام
وهي صواريخ باليستيه ثقيله ممكن ان تدمر
كل الجسور في النيبرو وممكن ان تضرب
وهي استراتيجيه وكانت جربت وممكن ان تحمل
رؤوس نوويه وكل هذا ممكن استخدامه ممكن ان
تبدا روسيا بقصف منشات صناعه القرار
ان تدمر اي
مستودعات للصواريخ وممكن ان نلقي بملايين
من القنابل الموجهه لدينا الكثير ما نقوم
به وما لم يسبق استخدامه حتى الان وممكن
ادخال اي نوع من هذه المعدات لاننا نرى
جيدا
المواجهات التي تتزايد وقد تزداد روسيا
باستخدام الصواريخ الكلاسيكيه عدا عن
المسيرات اسمع من السيد الكسندر سيد
الكسندر في المقابل الجانب الاوكراني
يتحدث عن هجوم مضاد وان الاستعدادات لهذا
الهجوم اكتملت اين سيبدا هذا الهجوم وكيف
يمكن تفسير
ازاله عنصر المفاجاه حول هذا الهدوم
السؤال للدكتور ايفان عفوا
عفوا السؤال للدكتور ايفان
بالنسبه للهجمات العكسيه او الهجمات هناك
مصطلحين هناك مجموعه من الخيارات والاداره
العسكريه خمسه منهم قالوا انهم يعلمون
جيدا اي انها عفوا انا لا احد يعلم اين
سيحدث ومتى
وهناك احتمالات كبيره ان هذا سيكون في
ميليتوبل وبحر الاوزوف لان حسب
الهجمات ممكن ان نقوم بتقسيم اجنحه القوات
الروسيه وحتى نسهل
الهجمات المستمره ممكن
كبير الباحثين في المعهد الاوكراني
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه كنت معنا
الخبير العسكري والمختص في الشؤون الناتو
[موسيقى]
الى ايران وفي الذكرى الخامسه الانسحاب
الرئيس الامريكيه السابق من الاتفاق
النووي اكدت الخارجيه الايرانيه ان احياء
الاتفاق بشان البرنامج النووي يبقى ممكنا
لكن المتحدث باسم الخارجيات الايرانيه
ناصر كنعاني حمل في مؤتمر صحفي الدول
الغربيه خصوصا الولايات المتحده مسؤوليه
التاخر في ذلك
هذا واكد متحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان الرئيس الامريكيه جو بايدن
ملتزم بعدم السماح لايران بحيازه سلاح
نووي واضافها في تصريحات للجزيره ان
الاداره الامريكيه لا تزال ترى ان
الدبلوماسيه هي الطريق الامثل للوصول الى
ذلك الهدف مضيفا ان واشنطن تبقي جميع
الخيارات قائمه بشان التعامل مع الملف
النووي الايراني
في الثامن من مايو ايار 2018 اعلن الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب انسحاب
بلاده من الاتفاق واصدر اوامر التنفيذيه
اعاد بموجبها فرض العقوبات التي رفعت
بعدها بعام تماما اعلن الرئيس الايراني
السابق حسن روحاني ان ايران ستتوقف عن
الامتثال لاجزاء من الاتفاق النووي بدات
معالم ذلك تظهر جليا الثاني قالت الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ان ايران خزانه
اليورانيوم بكميات تفوق المسموح بها 12
ضعفا انتخب بيضا رئيسا وفي يناير كانون
الثاني 2021 اكد امكانيه عوده بلاده
بالتشاور مع حلفائها الى الاتفاق النووي
في الاشهر الثلاثه الاولى من عام 2021
اتخذت ايران خطوات تضمنت تقييد عمل
المفتشين الدوليين ورفع التخصيب بدايه الى
20% ولاحقا الى 60% وفي اواخر تشرين
الثاني نوفمبر من العام نفسه استانفت
المباحثه فيفين تحدث استهران عن اتفاق
عادل وضمانات بعدم التكرار الانسحاب
الامريكي لكن الغزو الروسيه لاوكرانيا
القى بضلاله على المباحثات ليعلن الاتحاد
الاوروبي في مارس اذار الحاجه الى تعليق
المفاوضات بسبب عوامل خارجيه بدت مرتبطه
بطرح روسيا شروطا تتعلق بالعقوبات
المفروضه عليها وفي الثامن والعشرين من
الشهر نفسه استضافه الدوحه الجوله من
المباحثات غير المباشره جمعت واشنطن
وطهران برعايه من الاتحاد الاوروبي
واختتمت بعد يومين دون تحقيق تقدم المرجو
وفي السادس والعشرين من يوليو تموز الماضي
اعلن بوري الاقتراح مسوده نص جديد لاحياء
الاتفاق النووي محذرا من ازمه نوويه خطيره
في حال رفض الاتفاق بعد خمسه اشهر على
توقفها استانفت مفاوضات فيينا في الرابع
من اب اغسطس
لكن جمودا في مسار المفاوضات اوصل اطراف
الحوار الى طريق مسدود منذ الثامن من
اغسطس من العام الماضي وتوقفت معه امال
احياء الاتفاق النووي من جديد
[موسيقى]
تتجه الانظار في الولايات المتحده الى
الاجتماع المرتقب اليوم في البيت الابيض
بين الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن وقاده
الكونجرس في محاوله للوصول الى اتفاق بشان
رفع سقف الدين وتجنب تخلف الولايات
المتحده عن سداد ديونها ويطالب الجمهوريون
الرئيس بايدن بتخفيض نفقات بعض المشاريع
كشرط لرفع سقف الدين بينما يتمسك بايدن
برفع سقف الدين دون شروط كما جرت العاده
مع الادارات السابقه
ما لم يرفع الكونغرس سقف الدين العام
الامريكي خلال الشهر الحالي فان النتائج
ستكون كارثيه تحضير صريح وواضح من وزيره
الخزانه الامريكيه بشان ازمه الخلاف بين
البيت الابيض والجمهوريين في مجلس النواب
الامريكي
اولويتنا هي ان يقوم الكونجرس بواجبه ليست
هناك طريقه اخرى لحمايه نظامنا المالي
واقتصادنا سوى ان يقوم الكونجرس بعمله
ويرفع سقف الدين العام كي نتمكن من دفع
المستحقات المترتبه علينا
الازمه تفجرت حين اشترط الجمهوريون قبولهم
رفع سقف الدين مقابل تقليص الانفاق في
المشاريع التي اقرتها اداره بايدن خلال
عامين من الحكم وقد عرضت الاغلبيه
الجمهوريه رؤيتها لتحقيق ذلك عبر مشروع
قرار تمكنت من تمريره في مجلس النواب رغم
معارضه اربعه جمهوريين وجميع النواب
الديمقراطيين المشروع يعرض رفع سقف الدين
بتريليون ونصف ترليون دولار مقابل عدول
اداره بايدن عن عدد من مشاريعها بل الغاء
بعض مما حققته من اجندتها المحليه مثل
اعفاءات القروض الطلابيه او تطوير وتحديث
وكاله تحصيل الضرائب الفيدراليه وحتى
حوافز التشجيع على التحول نحو موارد
الطاقه النظيفه شروط يرى فيها البيت
الابيض ابتزازا غير مقبول ياخذ اقتصاد
البلاد رهينه خدمه
عمده حزبيه ضيقه ودعا قاده الكونغرس من
الحزبين للاجتماع معه في البيت الابيض
للوصول الى حل
الامور في واشنطن عاده لا تحل الا في
اللحظات الاخيره اعتقد ان بايدن كان يظن
انه سيظهر بدور البطل لعدم تفاوضه وسيظهر
الجمهوريين كالاشرار وهذا لم يحدث وبات
عليه ان يتنازل قليلا عن اجندته في حينما
كارث يخشى من ان يخسر رئاسه مجلس النواب
ان تعاون مع الديمقراطيين
هذا الاستعصاء ان استمر فستكون له اثار
خطيره للغايه على الاقتصاد الامريكي وعلى
النظام المالي العالمي برمته فعدم رفع سقف
الدين ستنتج عنه تداعيات تبدا بتخلف
الولايات المتحده عن سداد ديونها وتخفيض
التصنيف الائتماني للبلاد وانخفاض سعر
الدولار وتراجع الثقه به كاحتياطي نقدي
عالمي
تداعيات يخشى الخبراء ان تكون كارثيه ان
تعذر سد الفجوه بين اداره بايدن وخصومها
الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب خشيه مصحوبه
بامل التوصل الى توافق بعين اجتماع البيت
الابيض احمد هزيم الجزيره واشنطن
انضموا الينا من واشنطن الدكتور روبرت
سكوت خبير في معهد السياسه الاقتصاديه
الكبيره الخبراء في هذا المعهد اذا دكتور
روبرت على ماذا يتم التفاوض بين الرئيس
بايدن وقاده الكونجرس وما شكل التسويه
الممكنه
في الحقيقه اعتقد ان موضوع هذه المفاوضات
التي تجري بين الرئيس واعضاء الكونجرس
تتركز حول ما اذا كان الكونجرس سوف يوافق
على رفعه سقف الدين كما اشرتم في تقريركم
نحن نتحدث عن سقف سوف او مت سوف سوف نصل
اليها في شهر يونيو وفي حال لم يتم ذلك قد
يؤدي ذلك الى تداعيات ماليه كبيره على
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وعلى مستوى
العالم ونتحدث عن ركود اقتصادي يمكن ان
يضرب العالم وبالتالي هناك نحن على حافه
الهاويه في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان
اداره
لا تود ان يكون هناك شروط للموافقه على
رفع سقف الدين هناك مفاوضات يمكن تجري
بتوقيت مختلف ولكن بالنسبه الى موضوع رفح
سقف الدين على وجه الخصوص يود الرئيس
بايدن ان لا يكون مشروطا
[موسيقى]
الحقيقه اعتقد ان هذا السؤال هو سؤال
مفتوح تصعب الاجابه عليه يتوقف الامر على
مدى على المدى الذي يود الجمهوريون ان
يضغطوا الوصول اليه ومن ناحيه اخرى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ايضا يتوقف
فيها الموقف على قرار الرئيس الذي قد
يستخدم الصلاحيات الخاصه به لكي يستمر
بالانفاق الحكومي فوق سقف الدين نحن نتحدث
عن اجراء تم استحداثه على مستوى الكونجرس
منذ اكثر من عقد طيب في حال تمت التسويه
وتم رفع سقف الدين تريليون ونصف هل هذا ك
اعتقد ان اي رفع لسقف الدين هو مطلوب
من الجيد ان يحصل الرفع الى مستوى يكفي
لكي نصل الى مهله الانتخابات المقبله في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهذا امر يؤدي
الى احلال الاستقرار في الاسواق من ناحيه
اخرى قد يكون هناك تفاوض بالنسبه الى
القطاعات المختلفه ويحاول
الجمهوريون ان يضغطوا للحصول على موافقه
الاداره
الامريكيه لتنفيذ شروطهم ولكن عندما يكون
هناك اداء سيء للاقتصاد هناك معاناه على
مستوى الحزب الجمهوري في استطلاعات الراي
شكرا لك يا دكتور روبرتسكت كبير الخبراء
في معهد السياسه الاقتصاديه كنت معنا من
واشنط
ن
والان الى مشهد الانتخابات في تركيا
الى مشهد الانتخابات في تركيا حيث تواصلت
اليوم الحملات الانتخابيه للاحزاب
السياسيه في وقت بدا فيها العدو العكسي
للانتخابات بعد سته ايام ففي مدينه
شمال غربيه البلاد خاطب الرئيس التركي
ومرشحه تحالف الجمهور رجب طيب اردوغان
مناصليه متهما منافسه كمال كالجدار اوغلو
بتلقي الدعم من من سماهم قاده التنظيمات
الارهابيه في اشاره لحزب العمال
الكردستاني وايضا بالحصول على دعايه في
الدول الغربيه
اما كل جدار اجلو زعيم وحزب الشعب
الجمهوري ومرشح الطاوله السداسيه فقال انه
يراهن على شباب التركي لصناعه التغيير في
الانتخابات المقبله واوضح في خطابه امام
انصاره في مدينه اضنه بالجنوب التركي ان
نحو خمسه ملايين شاب تركي سيمارسون حقهم
في الاقتراع للمره الاولى في هذا
الانتخابات مؤكدا انهم من سيدفع التغيير
وبتحولها من النظام البرلماني الى النظام
الرئاسي عام 2018 دخلت تركيا مرحله جديده
تبدلت فيها معالم نظامها الانتخابي تتداخل
في النظام الجديد حسابات التحالفات
الحزبيه ويضع اجراء العتبه الانتخابيه
الاحزاب على محاكي موازين القوى والتمثيل
لكنه نظام تسعى المعارضه الرئيسيه الى
تغييره والعوده بالبلاد الى النظام
البرلماني في حال تمكنها من هزيمه اردوغان
في انتخابات الرئاسه
ينتخب الرئيس في النظام الرئاسي التركي
مباشره من الشعب لعهده مدتها خمس سنوات
ولا يمكن للبرلمان عزله من منصبه قبل
نهايه فتره ولايته ويجري التصويت في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه في جوله اولى تتطلب
حصول المرشح على اكثر من 50% من الاصوات
للفوز والا يمر السباق الى جوله ثانيه
يتنافس فيها المرشحان الفائزان باكبر عدد
من الاصوات في الجوله الاولى
ويمكن لاي حزب فاز بنسبه خمسه في المئه من
الاصوات وهي العتبه الانتخابيه في
الانتخابات البرلمانيه السابقه تقديم مرشح
للانتخابات الرئاسيه اما المستقلون فيتعين
عليهم جمع مئه الف توقيع من الناخبين
المسجلين من اجل الترشح في الانتخابات
البرلمانيه يصوت الناخبون لاختيار 600
نائب في مجلس الامه التركي الكبير وحتى
يفوز حزب ما بالاغلبيه البرلمانيه يتعين
عليه الح على اكثر من نصف مقاعد البرلمان
لا يمكن لاي حزب شغله مقاعد في البرلمان
الا بالحصول على سبعه في المئه من الاصوات
بمفرده او بالتحالف مع احزاب اخرى وهذه
العتبه خفضها قانون الانتخابات الجديد
الذي اقر شهر ابريل من العام الماضي بعدما
كانت سابقا محدده بعشره في المئه
ولتوزيع المقاعد على الاحزاب الفائزه
تعتمد تركيا نظام هوندا للتمثيل النسبي
المعتمد في سته عشره دوله في الاتحاد
الاوروبي وفق هذا النظام تجري قسمه عدد
الاصوات التي حصل عليها كل حزب سياسي في
كل دائره انتخابيه على الارقام بشكل
تصاعدي وصولا الى عدد مقاعد هذه الدائره
بعد ذلك يتم توزيع المقاعد على الاحزاب
حسب الارقام الاعلى الناتجه عن عمليه
القسمه وهذا النظام هو صيغه حسابيه معقده
ترجح كفه القوائم الانتخابيه الحاصله على
اكبر عدد من الاصوات وهي فعاله في تسهيل
تشكيل الاغلبيه البرلمانيه يقلل ذلك اهميه
التحالفات بالنسبه للاحزاب الصغيره اذ
اضحى حصولها على مقاعد في البرلمان
رهنا بعدد الاصوات التي يحصل عليها كل حزب
على حده لا على الاصوات التي يفوز بها
مجمل التحالف كما كان سابقا وما قد يجعل
الانتخابات البرلمانيه اكثر اهميه هي
المنافسه الشرسه المتوقعه بين التحالفات
لا سيما وان الهدف الرئيسي للتحالف
المعارضه الاكبر هو العوده بالبلاد الى
النظام البرلماني وذاك امر يحتاج لعرضه
على استفتاء شعبي وهو ما لن يتم الا
بتصويت ثلثي مقاعد البرلمان او نسبه 60%
على الاقل من النواب
ينضم الينا من اسطنبول ينال جوكسين الباحث
في الاعلام السياسي سيد ينال هي
الانتخابات الثانيه
عقب تغيير النظام كيف تختلف انتخابات
اليوم عما كانت عليه في 2018
يس هذه النار
نحن نتحدث عن الانتخابات الثانيه بعد
تغيير الانتظام وهناك اسباب متعدده
لانتظار نتيجه هذه الانتخابات حيث انها
سوف
تؤثر على مستقبل تركيا في البرلمان التركي
التسليط تسليط الضوء الان هو على
التحالفات بين الاحزاب المختلفه وهو امر
اختلف واصبح اساسي بالنسبه الى الانتخابات
قمت ببحوث ميدانيه بالنسبه الى راي
الناخبين وهناك متابعه من قبل الناخبين عن
كثب لاتخاذ القرار بشان التصويت في
الانتخابات المقبله وبالتالي يمكننا ان
نقول ان المنافسه السياسيه تجري بشكل علني
و بطريقه ديمقراطيه يمكننا ان نستمع الى
المشاريع الانتخابيه للاحزاب المختلفه
والشخصيات المختلفه يمكنني ان ابدا
بشرح
النظام الانتخابي والسياسي بشكل
يعني شرحنا النظام الانتخابي والسياسيه من
خلال هذا التقرير الذي عرضناه ولكن كيف
تفسر الاهتمام الدولي والاقليمي بهذه
الانتخابات
نعم بالفعل نحن نتحدث عن انتخابات مهمه من
المنظور الدولي لانها سوف تحدد السياسه
الخارجيه
لتركيا ويمكننا ان نرى ان تركيا تؤثر في
قرارات اقليميه ودوليه والناخبون لديهم
مسؤوليه في هذا السياق
والمعارضه تحاول ان تعمل على برنامج
يغير
السياسه الخارجيه خصوصا بالنسبه الى
العلاقات مع الاتحاد الاوروبي وحلف شمال
الاطلسي والدول الغربيه وبالتالي اذا ما
وصلت المعارضه الى سده الحكم في
الانتخابات المقبله تتحدث المعارضه عن جسر
الهوه معلومات المتحده الامريكيه والاتحاد
الاوروبي والدول الغربيه الاخرى وهذا يعني
كبيره في السياسه الخارجيه التركيه حيث ان
تركيا تؤدي دورا اساسيا يتسم بالاتزان
والتوازن الدبلوماسي والسياسي واجراء
الوسطات بين الجهات المختلفه وهذا ما
ارساه الحكم الحالي في تركيا بقياده
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وما رايناه بالنظر
الى التطورات الاخيره ينال البحث في
الاعلام السياسي شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
مؤلمه بالفعل معاناه جديده هي مره اخرى في
القاره الافريقيه للاسف هذه الصور التي
تبعناها كانت من الكونغو الديمقراطيه
وفيها يبكي الناس احباب لهم فقدوهم خلال
فيضانات جارفه مرت باكثر من بلد وفي هذا
البلد وحده
400 قتل واثنا عشر الف اسره ستعاني اكثر
بعد اليوم هي معاناه لا ناقه لهم فيها ولا
جمل وفي هذا تعبير ضمني للامين العام
للامم المتحده الذي قال انما يحدث تغيير
مناخي وان هؤلاء يدفعون فاتوره فاتوره امر
لم يساهموا فيه نهايه جوله الحصاد الليله
تصبحون على الف خير
[موسيقى]